quiero saludar en este momento a
antonella marte analista política y
directora del center for one en américa
en washington dc
antonella la saludo como carl a las
declaraciones del ministro de exteriores
bielorruso para los gobiernos de
occidente buenos dias raúl si
efectivamente como bien lo decías el
ministro de exteriores de bielorrusia
habla de misma key denunció este sábado
en la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas esa imposición no de sanciones
contra el país que según él perjudicaría
claramente a todos no nos olvidemos esto
que es tan importante bielorrusia vive
está sumergida en una crisis muy grave
desde que comenzaron todas estas masivas
manifestaciones y protestas ante el
fraude electoral en los comicios el
régimen de lukashenko claramente se vio
obligado a esto bien lo sabemos a pedir
el apoyo de rusia para poder superar
esta coyuntura y claramente ha
intensificado la persecución de
manifestantes opositores y periodistas
esto todas las últimas en las últimas
semanas pero claramente hay un fuerte
contraataque a los países occidentales
ahora antonella también hablaron los
primeros ministros del reino unido-
boris johnson y el de india narendra
modi que se enfocaron en la lucha contra
la pandemia de coves 19 el desarrollo de
las vacunas contra esta enfermedad le
pregunto si hay más críticas que
respaldó a la onu en su rol en cuanto a
esta pandemia de corona because ver a
raúl yo creo que hay mucha más crítica
que otra cosa y esto no solamente en lo
que hemos visto la jornada de ayer sino
a lo largo de toda esta este aniversario
de las naciones unidas ayer el primer
ministro del reino unido- boris johnson
llamaba a la unión mundial para poder
hacer frente al coi 19 y dio
precisamente en la clave cuando dijo que
el comité unió a la humanidad como nunca
antes pero que la crisis generada se
volvió de alguna forma una fuerza
demasiado potente para fomentar la
división no y creo que esto es a lo que
hoy nos estamos enfrentando boris
johnson aseguró que este la noción de la
comunidad internacional estos conceptos
que teníamos tan claros para el siglo 21
que al menos eso eso parecía están
completamente destrozadas y esas fueron
las la espalda
de boris johnson al menos ayer y como no
se puede continuar de esta manera por lo
que claramente el sistema está hoy ante
una crisis existencial así como lo están
las naciones unidas al parecer de estas
jornadas también recordemos bolt johnson
e hizo una fuerte crítica al régimen
comunista chino por por las violaciones
a las libertades en hong kong y bueno
las jornadas de este aniversario número
75 de las naciones unidas nos han
mostrado en una buena parte esta crisis
existencial si se puede decir dentro del
organismo internacional